I was working on a job and I came home
one day I told my former wife I said
that guy Berta I work for is stupid that
night I could not sleep well here was a
guy that was controlling my life and the
truth that I had to come to grips with
that I wasn't in charge of my destiny
the truth was that I wasn't giving all
that I had the truth was that there are
some things that I wanted to do but I
didn't have the courage to act on those
things and the truth was that Birchall's
was a blessing to me he made life so
miserable for me I had to start looking
at my life differently I started going
to work earlier I started being the last
one to leave there I started working
harder than anybody else the other guys
why would you work so hard less I said
I'm not working for them I have been
cheating Burt I thought I've been
cheating myself and my family wherever
you are whatever you're doing do it with
everything that you have develop the
habit of giving more than what you're
paid for develop the habit of setting
standards that others will be measured
by do not go where the path may lead but
go where there is no path and leave a
trail and in the process of working on
your dreams you are going to incur a lot
of disappointment a lot of failure a lot
of pain a lot of setbacks a lot of
defeats but in the process of doing that
you will discover some things about
yourself that you don't know right now
what you will realize is that you have
greatness within you what you'll realize
is that you're more powerful than you
can ever begin to imagine what you will
realize is that you're greater than your
circumstances that you don't have to go
through life being a victim but I'm at a
high school teacher who one day changed
my life I was waiting on another student
and when he came in he said to me young
man go to the board and write what I'm
about to tell you and I said I can't do
that turn he said why not I said because
I'm magica bula mentally [ __ ]
and he came from behind his desk and he
looked at me he said don't ever say that
again
someone's opinion of you does not have
to become your reality you just watched
two amazing clips from Les Brown take
the next three minutes to sit quietly
and think about how you can apply them
to your business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]